Hi, I'm talking to you again about the
Miguel Garza non-surgery bulls in Monclova.
This time I want to present a
video about colonoscopy, the
procedure we use to
detect and treat diseases
of the colon, rectum and anus, and which is also an
invaluable tool for  early detection
of colon cancer we hope it will
be useful for you a
lower gastrointestinal endoscopy also
called a colonoscopy or sigmoidoscopy
allows the doctor to see the
mucosal lining of the lower gastrointestinal tract
the procedure is used as a
screening test in people without symptoms or
to help diagnose a
unexplained abdominal pain rectal bleeding
or a change in bowel habits may
detect inflammation
infections ulcers diverticulosis
narrowing of the intestine
colorectal polyps cancer or other problems
that may be present
before the procedure you will need to
undergo an internal preparation
depending on the type of medication
prescribed you will need to start 1-3
days before the procedure you will need to
modify your diet and take medication
which will help cleanse your intestines
and prepare for the procedure
the procedure is performed
using an endoscope which is
a long, flexible, thin tube with a light and
a small video camera attached to the
end the camera transmits the images
to a monitor
in one sign and two copies the endoscope
only reaches the upper part of the descending colon
in a colonoscopy the endoscope
reaches the entire  length of the colon to
its connection to the small intestine
the presence of the scope and air
may cause you to feel pressure or
cramping as well as the need to
pass gas this is considered a
normal part of the procedure your
doctor may ask you to change your
position slightly  so you can
more easily maneuver the endoscope
through curves.  If you experience pain in your large intestine,
notify your doctor
immediately. In some cases, your doctor
may find it necessary to take
samples for a biopsy. A
biopsy helps distinguish between
benign and cancerous tissue and can help
determine the cause of bleeding,
inflammation, or disease.  diarrhea often
biopsies are done even if the
doctor does not suspect cancer
if one or more polyps are found
usually the doctor removes them
using a procedure called a
polypectomy an extractor forceps is usually used
to remove the
polyps and then the bases are cauterized
to control  bleeding
at the end of the procedure the endoscope is removed
from the colon a sigmoidoscopy
usually takes about 20 minutes
while a colonoscopy can take between
30 minutes and an hour
we remind you that for any
information and comments we are on the
lookout in any of our
forms of contact
we hope  solve your doubts  and be able to
serve you
[Music]